welcome to markiplier makes egg hold
safety-net
basket tower pile egg drop catcher it's
it's an egg you drop an egg into this
thing that you make to make the egg not
break we all did this all of us have
done this and I'm not just using this as
a redemption because when I did it my
teacher just so happened to miss my
pitcher and then they decided not to
redo it because that counter does break
which is the most thing in the
history of but this isn't the
reason why I'm doing this over again
that would be petty that would be
ridiculous and that would be going back
to a childhood that frankly things don't
really matter it's just an egg drop if
they didn't want to do it again that's
their own rules their own dumb stupid
stupid rules what are you doing anyway
these are the eggs were gonna do these
eggs are not broken oh that's your pie
we're gonna make two different types of
protectors we're gonna make an egg crash
pad we're gonna drop the egg from about
a story up into this thing we'll get
three tries apiece so if there's some
fluke where the egg doesn't go into the
basket that won't count because we'll do
it again okay uh Tyler give me the
history of egg there once was this
debate about chickens and eggs and which
came first but eggs that they come out
of chickens and they have to be
fertilized in order for them to hatch so
there has to be a rooster involved so
therefore it's it's a tough debate
because no matter what you're gonna have
to have either two eggs or a chicken and
a rooster you can't have one or the
other and so the history of eggs is that
and legs lays them you didn't really
reach a conclusion there because it's an
end and it's unanswerable egg nygma
alright oh you you made a pun and you
hate puns
I don't hate puns I just hate waves now
we're gonna make two different types
we're gonna make the crash pad and then
we're gonna make an envelope no
parachutes allowed there's a
certain time limit of construction that
we have certain materials get the
material okay so we got a bunch of
materials with which we can make these
things balloons are out that's cheating
we got sponges we got like spritz
creamer we got rubber cement I think
it's like a master baiter oh yeah even
get it sticky it is sticky
oh it's been used we've got this okay
we've got okay this you can't use the
pillow itself you have to open the
pillow and use the stuffing in the
pillow okay
towel then allow it
toilet paper toilet paper roll and more
flute okay the basket is where you're
putting it in so that we have a target
to go for you know yeah okay
okay so we're gonna build the crash pad
first all right so these are materials
that we have to work with please do not
put that on me that's so gross it's
disgusting that's pretty gross yes weird
right all right okay how much time do we
have you ask three minutes three minutes
three minutes to build your egg catcher
okay that sounds fair
yeah sure all right set a timer okay no
geez now we'll only be able to build the
other thing with what we have left over
so oh my god how much time do that oh
geez oh is our plan Oh No
any second out
oh come on give give give give give
give give give give give give
oh okay you're done you're done
what I'm trying to make a shock mount a
catcher the catcher all right so you
built your yeah well I get to put this
back inside because it did just fall
over it okay that's fair present your
crashers or isn't that good though birds
make really good things mine's a whole
spongy fluff there's sponge centered
tissue paper and fluff all right that
sounds good and duct tape mine mine is
freestanding the box provides support
there's a little bit of a wall so if it
falls in it won't bounce out it's got a
lot of fluff it's mostly streamer a
little bit of pillow and some tissues
and then I've wrapped a few of it inside
with rubber bands on the outside with
duct tape i small cylindrical box thing
with a rubber band on top which is gonna
just make the egg bounce away all right
cool nice nice job set those aside can I
now make the cushion sure man all right
once again we'll have three minutes four
minutes you think okay four minutes will
do four minutes a little more time I
would I've been already gonna veto you
can't just put it in this because that
that seems unfair but you can use this
material as part of it yeah you have to
cut it yeah you have to cut that all
right who's ready
I don't know nobody could do is you
could fix that up in your time and then
make a cross that's when I will do that
do that you can do that you can finish
your envelope and then okay okay oh you
cut that open really pink
Oh mine's not gonna be color-coordinated
okay all right so I made similar to my
other one I wanted to create a tube that
would have some rigidity to it upright
so that it could fall and then hopefully
it doesn't tumble out so it sits inside
of a a like sploosh ball in here it's
pretty well secured we'll just see if it
survives mine's the foamy tea with the
big tube for the egg to fit in and with
the lid guy to cover it up and there's
stuffing it's already attached to go
inside to cover it up so then it goes
down this way because there's more
weight on this side and then
it kind of bounces down it's kind of got
cushioning all around so that it will
just be like a blue okay mine is failure
you didn't even finish Mosley maybe
it'll work you never know Thanks
[Laughter]
so what we're gonna do next
apparently is we're gonna take these
outside we're gonna drop them we'll have
one camera up top one camera down below
we'll drop our own things we'll start
with the crash pads we'll finish with
these you love the same one for both
multifunctional I like it it's good we
insert the eggs and these guys now yeah
you can into your oh wait he can't do
that yes the way have fun and let's get
outside are you feeling I tried I tried
to make a shock mount my idea was that I
was gonna put the egg in here and it was
sort of gonna rest in between all of
them and then when it hit the ground it
would just sort of wobble in between but
I didn't have enough time to make a
correct one so this was made instead and
I hate it and now I only have this I
don't have anything else well you catch
this and put this in the basket I got it
wait we're doing catchers I got it wait
first you want to move me to move some
rubber bands no no keep it as by design
okay do you have the eggs I have an egg
you have an egg you get three tries at
this oh hold on let me get my ring get
the whole egg thing alright uh I just
wanted to win cuz I don't want to see
him cry he's changed he seems really
bummed out of it I really want him to
hit the target I think even if it breaks
if he exists the bourbons yeah okay I
have three eggs alright good you get the
whole egg thing cuz we're also gonna
need eggs are there three tries three
tries you got this man should we move
the basket clothes need it closer man
I can get it like say something before
it guys one liftoff close very close I
think you've got your eye in I've got my
prize I love you know I'm turned away
that wasn't enough oh I like that the
corpse or the one is still on the corner
there big boy
egg boy if it says EB you're gonna live
believe and have faith in the free fall
in the cushion below huh
whoa it lived whoa egg boy number two
you saw that guy do it you got this
trust and have faith ooh that one broke
yeah we got a crack all right that was
good
well that's okay big man what's up do
you live
Wow no oh that's a break
what yeah yep sorry well you got one
isn't gonna what you need you got one no
well now we just got see if I can get
two I win right hi Amy I love you
okay that's a lot farther than I thought
it'd be okay I realized my flaw now I
made my target real small you're an
inanimate object but if you land in this
I'll give you a million dollars oh did
he make it you have a live you did live
to straighten my crash pad just a little
bit
you didn't fluff mine back you didn't
ask me to oh that's good damn it you
didn't ask me to is that - nope broke
wait no wait it lived could you do all
three though that's the goal
all three survivors do you need a
correction uh just slightly to your left
just terribly slightly not good
yes it is no he broke ah damn it still -
yeah yeah that was quite a bounce on
that one unfortunately you actually hit
the edge of the cardboard with Oh oops
yeah none of them actually went in your
tissue paper they just bounced and
survived the axis shows the rigidity of
my build and how capable I was do you
want to drop one more egg for fun even
lift me yeah oh just alright you ready
yeah wait combine all three of ours to
the power oh not at both at once
what combined our pads no no that
wouldn't fellow that one stuck to my
thumb on the way out
yeah that wouldn't go all the way down
that was not my fault
okay since I'm already up here I'll do
my other one I already know this is
gonna survive is it are we put letting
it land in the crate or should it be the
concrete because concrete concrete
alright three two one
okay oh boy okay maybe my design
not so flawless after all you want me to
leave the body you leave the body
well move over a little bit though you
don't want it landing on the body you're
right that just be cruel it'd be
disrespectful alright here we go big guy
we go big guy here we go big guy don't
turn over oh lift it's safe yeah there's
a little bit of blood in here but I
think that's okay
three two one oh oh he he exploded one
for three do you want to go oh we go
yeah yeah okay yuck
look I did okay these guys I know they
rigged it Tyler is such a blowhard he
started blowing as soon as it got down
below his eye level he pushed it down
twist it side ways it really undid me
unfair but you know I played by the
rules all right boy this is it
tell you that you suck I believe in you
that's well do you want the good news or
the bad news
he broke yeah he did what it kind of
spooked all I know it's at the bottom
there's no good news you've got a lot of
entry points you could put it in a lot
of different places you're right mm-hmm
I'm doing that I'm putting it in a hole
I think he's repackaging it he played it
like working on it I'm putting the fluff
back into its fluff balls
I think it's cheating I think it's
cheating I'm done all right all right I
believe in you all right Oh promise
baby's in that big fluff ball there
where there's no trace of the body we're
good Wow well your your contraption
ain't doing so good it's kind of falling
apart yeah no let's toss ups and downs
okay yet
you should have shuffled the fluff into
a rubberband look got it kind of I say
you only get 20 seconds to reload
otherwise that does seem a little JT one
more you could do it I could see okay
that's not a good thing if you can see
it that's probably not probably Heidi
[Laughter]
and you see him one last we tied on that
one my turn on that one on our I will
redeem myself
okay all right listen Tyler's a cheating
cook but you know I got to give him to
him he did get that one the other ones
though were really terrible mine was
only a victim of Tyler's sabotage I
didn't sabotage him at all he is just a
huge douche sometimes and I just will
hope he knows that before he's dead
hi Tyler hi hey how you doing I'm good
and feel like you're alive I feel like
my baby's dead a lot of them great I
saved one you know I'm 33 and a third
percent success rate it's not good it's
very poor all right man maybe you should
put it inside the thing no you don't
know how does it works I don't
understand the science behind it I don't
you know I'm sorry man you know what's
good is the corpses of the failed ones
will add to the cushioning really or
don't try to catch me are you so ashamed
of it you just don't want to touch it
this one's the one okay okay is it
inside at this time
yeah just know this will be good I trust
this
I did the same thing man just toss me
every last try man last my best try he's
got this right Tyler I believe he does
if history has shown us a blind squirrel
gets a nut what I don't know
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right okay all right let's see if
there's one we've got a live one yes
using the horrifying other eggs that's
one for me that's all right but your
ratio really goes down because you got a
lot more broken now I mean I'll give you
this one but what does it was is like
five other eggs it was the rest of the
eggs so you lost two more this time five
seven you've lost ten eggs two one good
one
Tyler ain't doing so good but that egg
is in the raft all right put him on the
table good job man real proud of you all
right well this has been another
successful markiplier makes as the
standings go I won the first round for
the crash pad Tyler and I tied for the
last one if you go by Ethan's weird
rules we all tied on the last ones but I
don't think that's true how long is this
apple juice been here anyway yeah so if
you got other ideas for Martin bar mix
put them in the comments below if you
want to see other markiplier mix that
we've done check out the description
also check out the description for this
guy Tyler here he streams at apocalypta
underscore 12 and that's grant gameplays
the crank game plays you can find him on
youtube and sometimes twitch and my name
is ben mark bar thanks so much and as
always we'll see you next one oh boy i'm
on twitch